ALRIGHT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN GOOD MORNING WE
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE DELAY
STARTED IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME YOU TO THE
JUNE TWENTY FOURTH EDITION WE
DO HAVE AUTHORS- IN THE HOUSE
HERE TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
STARTING WITH THE CINEMA QUIRK
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
TO SIN NUMBER THAN BEING. AT
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY WE DO HAVE A-
TOLL FREE LIVE LINE NUMBER.
THAT NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX FOUR
pFREE NUMBER TO PARTICIPATE IN
COMING ON IN THE BILL TODAY IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE
SIX. FOUR FOUR THREE SIX THE
CODE IS SEVEN NINE NINE. NINE
EIGHT ZERO. I WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO TAKE CARE OF SOME QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING. FIRST AND
FOREMOST. AB EIGHT NINE FIVE
NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER FOUR ON OUR
AGENDA. THAT ITEM WAS
TEMPORARILY PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR FROM TODAY'S AGENDA-
THAT BILL SHOULD BE BACK IN
FRONT OF US. FIRST THING NEXT
WEEK. THAT'S GONNA LEAVE AT
FIVE BILLS. ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
THREE WITH THE AUTHOR
PRESENTING HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OF THE THREE. INTO PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT. AND THAT MEANS OUR
TO CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS ARE
ITEM NMBER ONE EIGHTY TO
NINETY SIX. AND I. TO NINETY
FIVE AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE. SO
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THAT WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
THEN WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
MOTION TO BE ABLE TO APPROVE
TODAY'S CONSENT COUNTER. MISTER
CONSULTANT GOOD MORNING MR
CANAL IF YOU CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL IN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. HERE REQUIRE
PRESIDENT SENATOR NIELSEN SEN
PRESIDENT SENATOR TORONTO
TORONTO PRESENT SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER PRESENT YOU HAVE A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM IS BEEN ESTABLISHED LAYS
IN GERMAN GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION
FOR THE MOTION TO APPROVE OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF ITEMS
NUMBER ONE IN ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THAT MR CONSULTANT MR CANAL CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL UNDER
CONSENT CALENDAR THE MOTION IS
TO ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATOR MCGUIRE BY THE FIRE HIS
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIS
SENATOR TORONTO TORONTO HIS
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER AYE IT'S
CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO VOTE FOR
YOUR VOTE FOR TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPENING AT THE MAJORITY LEADER
ON LACING GENTLEMEN NOW WE WANT
TO REMIND YOU WHEN YOU TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY.
THAT WHEN YOU CALL.
877-336-4436 YOU'RE GONNA BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR- IT TO
DIAL ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE GOING TO
REMIND FOLKS TO PLEASE MUTE
YOUR DEVICE THATYOU'RE GOING
TO BE SPEAKING ON TODAY. AT TO
ENSURE THAT WE LESSEN FEEDBACK
COMING INTO THE HEARING ROOM IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT AN
INDIVIDUAL BECOMES UNRULY IT
WHETHER IT'S ON THE PHONE OR
HERE IN. THE CHAMBERS WE ARE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE THEM REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HERE IN THE CHAMBER OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. SO
LAYS IN GERMAN LET'S GET RIGHT
INTO IT WE WELCOME. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COURT TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT HE HAS BEEN WORKING ON
THIS BILL WITH US AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
IS THE NUMBER. FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS THE FLOOR
IS YOURS ON AB. FIVE FOUR FIVE
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE. THE CHAIR
AND MEMBER- IT IS IT- MY
PLEASURE TO PRESENT A. B. FIVE
FORTY FIVE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD FOR
WORKING ON AMENDMENTS- WHICH
WERE PRIMARILY DEALT WITH
PRIVACY AND ALSO TO- TRYING TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
WOULD BE DONE AT THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD. ARE TO ENSURE THAT-
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL STATE COST-
SOME OF THE MAJOR TAX
EXPENDITURES IN CALIFORNIA OF
REDIRECTED HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN FUNDING. FROM
EDUCATION AND OTHER VITAL
SERVICES FOR YEARS WITHOUT ANY
RE REFER REVIEW. TO CONFIRM
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS.
ADDITIONALLY A TWENTY SIXTEEN
STATE AUDIT FOUND THAT THE LACK
OF OVERSIGHT OR VALUATION MAY
BE DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE IF
SOME TAX CREDITS OR EXEMPTIONS
WERE FOR FAILING THEIR PURPOSE.
TO ADDRESS THIS FLASK OF
OVERSIGHT AB FIVE FORTY FIVE
INITIATES A ONE TIME
COMPREHENSIVE PEER REVIEWED
ASSESSMENT BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH CENTER. BUT
TO EVALUATE THE MOST COSTLY TAX
EXPENDITURE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
ACCUMULATED IN MORE A MORE THAN
A BILLION DOLLARS TO FOUR
POINT. REVENUE OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS AB FIVE FORTY FIVE
WILL SIMPLY ASK YOU SEE REACH.
RESEARCH CENTER TO ANALYZE THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS.
THAT MAJOR TAX EXPENDITURES
HAVE IN THE STATE AND VERIFYING
THE BENEFITS THE STATE GETS
FROM THESE PROGRAMS. WILL ALSO
DETERMINE THE OPTIONS FOR
IMPROVING THE PROGRAMMER
REDUCING THEIR IMPACT TO THE
GENERAL FUND. AB FIVE FORTY
FIVE PROVIDES A TOOL FROM FOR
ME IN OUR FUTURE POLICY
DECISIONS AND ENSURING THE BEST
USE OF LIMITED PUBLIC DOLLARS-
THE REPORT WOULD BE DUE IN
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR I WOULD THAN ANTICIPATED
THIS COMMITTEE. THIS COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS THE REVENUE TAX IN
THE ASSEMBLY- WOULD TAKE A LOOK
AT THE REPORT AND DECIDE WHAT
TO DO NEXT- CHAU TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
AND JUST CONFIRMING YOUR TAKING
THE SENTIMENTS I KNOW YOU ARE
YOU SEE I'M TAKING ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND ADDITION TO A COUPLE THAT
F. T. B. SUGGESTED JUST TODAY-
AND MY STAFF IS CAN. BE USED-
COMMUNICATING WITH YOUR STAFF-
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THOSE
SAID MEN MENTORING THERE AND
THAT THE WORDING IS CORRECT
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP SERPENTINE QUEUE
FOR BEING SO GOOD TO WORK WITH-
AND PLEASE PASS ON OUR THANKS
YOUR STAFF AS WELL AS A MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT THESE IN GERMAN LEAD
TO LEAD SUPPORT WHEN THIS IS ON
THE LINE FOR FIRST GOING TO
START WITH KATIE HARTMAN THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
MISS HARTMAN FLORES YOURS HERE
NOW I'M COMMITTEE. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBER KATIE
HARTMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. I'M PGA
PRO DOCTOR OF THIS BILL AND WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK FOR HER TO WORK ON THAT-
I'LL BE BRIEF AND THE AUTHOR
DID A GREAT JOB- BUT JUST WANT
TO MAKE IT. A COUPLE OF POINTS-
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE RECORDED A TOTAL OF
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
TAX EXPENDITURES- REPORTED LAST
YEAR. AND THAT. NUMBER
CONTINUES TO GROW- THAT
OBVIOUSLY HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON
OUR STATE BUDGET AND EDUCATION
FUNDING THANKS APPROXIMATELY
40% OF THE BUDGET DEDICATED TO
U. K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION. THAT
MEANS APPROXIMATELY. THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IS REDIRECTED
AWAY FROM SCHOOLS IN THE FORM
OF TAX EXPENDITURES EACH YEAR-
AND MANY OF THESE ARE HAD NEVER
BEEN- REVIEWED OR EVALUATED- SO
THIS BILL IS. NOT PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE ANY OF TAX
EXPENDITURES ASSEMBLY. TO
PROVIDE THE STATE WITH MORE
INFORMATION ON SOME OF THE MORE
COSTLY EXPENDITURES- AND- GET
THEIR ACCOMPLISHING THEIR THEIR
GOAL. AND FELT YOU KNOW THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY. AND ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISS HARTMAN. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE OUR
SECOND FINALLY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FOUR FIVE
THAT'S CHRISTY BAMA. FROM
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. IT'S ABOUT YOUR
NOW AND COMMITTEE FLOOR. SHORES
PLEASE PROCEED YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU KILEY LIST
CHAIRMAN CHRISTY ABOUT ON THE-
OF THE K. PROFESSION FIRE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WELL
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FORTY FIVE. WHICH
WILL INITIATE THE COOPERATIVE
ASSESSMENT FROM THE SCRIBED BY
THE AUTHOR PARTICULARLY IN THE
PRIOR WITNESS. AS YOU KNOW OVER
THE YEARS LEGISLATION QUICKLY
TURNED TO TAX CREDITS ADVANCE
POLICY INTERESTS AND GRANTED
TARGETED RELIEF. BUT THESE
DECISIONS ARE SIGNIFICANT AND
SOMETIMES ARE MADE WITHOUT
FULLY UNDERSTANDING DEBATING
THE IMPACT OF THOSE CREDIT- ON
THE FUTURE FOR A FIVE. ANY
SICKENING LOOK BACK TO SEE IF
THEY NEED THE ACTUAL POLICY
GOALS STATED. EVERY DOLLAR TAX
CREDIT COUNTRY GENERAL FUND IS
TAKEN FROM CRITICAL STATE
SERVICES INCLUDING FIRE
PROTECTION PROTECTION AND
WILDFIRE MITIGATION THE
SERVICE. THAT'S A CLEAR
PRIORITY THAT WE SHARE WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO FACE MASSIVE AND
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN THE
NEAR TERM HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED
TO PROTECT CRUCIAL REVENUES TO
FUND. THIS FIREFIGHT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ARE ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVING ITS
RETURN ON INVESTMENT. WE
BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE PROVIDES A REGULAR SYSTEM
EVALUATION AND METRICS TO
ASSESS ECONOMIC BENEFITS
CREATED BY THESE CREDIT. ALSO
FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE TODAY. THANK YOU SOMUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY
THEY SYNGENTA COMMITTEE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN ADDITION TO MISS
GONNA MISS HARTMAN IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. WE'RE GOING TO
CHECK IN ON THREE DIFFERENT AND
MEDIUMS FIRST RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE OF LIKE SPEAK
HEARING SEEN NINE. SIT ARE
SEARCHING IS GONNA NOW- CHECK
IN HERE IN ON OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
IT'S CHECKED OVERFLOW ROOM
HEARING SEEN NO ONE RISE IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO ART
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE WELCOME
INDIVIDUALS BE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A TELECONFERENCE LINE TODAY
TO COMMENT ON ANY BILL THE
PHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR
THREE SIX. IN THIS- IS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES- IN ELIMINATING
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND AS
WELL AS AND HEARING TO SOCIAL.
DISTANCE IN FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES- WE ARE OING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE SO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN LET'S GO
TO OUR MODERATOR MR MODERATOR
CAN WE PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE FOUR FIVE NOW. YES IN
A FEW INSTEAD OF FIVE FOUR FIVE
WHICH SPEAK PLEASE PRSS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
START WITH MY NUMBER NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DOWNLOAD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. INCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND NEXT COLOR LINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CALLING PAT YOU'RE
ON THE HAVE IT LET THE END OF
THE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
THE PARK THANKS CONNIE. MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY INDIVIDUAL ANY INDIVIDUALS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
RECORD TODAY SO WE'RE GONNA
START HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE HERE AND SEE WHEN KNOWN
RISE WE'RE GONNA GO TO OVERFLOW
ROOM. CHECKING IN- OVERFLOW
ROOM KNOWN AS AN OVERFLOW ROOM
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO A
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. FIVE FOUR FIVE NOW. AND
IT'S LIKE SPEAKING OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE FOUR FIVE THE FIRST
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT MISS MODERATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR GOING TO BRING THIS
BILL BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR EMOTION- CENTER
DRAWS OF QUESTIONS COMES PLEASE
YES- WHEN APPROPRIATE I'D LIKE
TO MOVE. THE BILL BUT I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE- MUSEUM- I
REALLY. BELIEVE THIS IS. I MEAN
THIS IS A VERY GOOD I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. BOB THE KIDS BY
TWO EVERY TIME THERE'S A- TAX
CREDIT HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
WHERE IS THAT GOING TO WARS
AGAIN AND- PUTS IT REALLY DOING
FOR FOLKS- AND YOUR INCLUDING A
LOT HERE TO START. I HOPE. THAT
WE COULD DO EVEN MORE AND
EXPANDED IN THE FUTURE I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT YOU AMEND THAT
OR DO THAT. WITH THIS BILL- BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER. OF OTHER
THINGS THAT I THINK. WE NEED TO
TAKE INTO. CONSIDERATION WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE TAX CREDITS.
AND THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
REFERENCE. TO IT. WHEN THERE'S
THAT SAYS ECONOMIC SOCIAL.
ANOTHER IMPACTS. OF THAT THE
TAX EXPENDITURE. WOULD HAVE AND
APPROPRIATE. SO YOU KNOW OF AND
I'M THINKING OF- I HAVE A BILL
FOR EXAMPLE IT'S TRYING TO BE
VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT OUR
TRANSPORTATION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. HOW MANY JOBS WOULD
KIND OF JOBS WITH THE QUALITY
OF THE JOBS AT CENTER. SO I
THINK IT'S THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED BECAUSE- WHAT WE
INVEST THESE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WHAT'S THE
OVERALL GOING TO PRODUCE FOR
CALIFORNIA WHAT ARE WE GETTING
OUT OF IT AS AS CALIFORNIANS SO.
I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU I HOPE
IN THE FUTURE AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD THE NEXT STEPS- INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER DRAWS ON THE
FLOORS IN THE RECORD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND PLEASE- I AGREE.
ALL RIGHT I LIKE IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATE RECORD OR IF WE
HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER DRIVES-
IN AB FIVE FORTY FIVE- ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS FROM COMMITTEE
HEARING SEEN NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER SIMMONS
ASPIRO VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
IS IN THE RECORD ALL RIGHT
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRIVE SO MISTER NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE MOTIONAND THEN
CALL THEM. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE MCGUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO IT SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. TWO ONE HI
THERE WE GO WE GOT TO ONE VOTE
LAYS IN GERMAN NEVER GONNA KEEP
THAT BILL ON CALL AND ALLOW-
CENTER WINNER IN THE MAJORITY
TO BE A ADELINE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THEY WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL. BUT IN GENERAL NOT TO
BE MOVINGON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
ON OUR AGENDA AND SECOND
THOUGH- IN- FOR TODAY'S HEARING
THIS IS AB FORTINO TO A REALLY
GOOD BILL BY IS A MEMBER OF THE
BEING. FOCUSING ON ADDITIONAL
FEES THAT WE NEED- AFTER WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED THE MARKET PLAY
FACILITATOR ACT REALLY GRATEFUL
TRULY THAT- DECEMBER IS
FOCUSING ON THIS. STATE IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IN THE
GOODISON LIMITS CAN BE
ADVANCING A TRUNCATED VERSION
OF HIS STATEMENT MR SOME MEMBER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR STRUCTURE AND MEMBERS I
THINK YOU JUST GAVE MY
PRESENTATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. I APOLOGIZE SIR I
DID NOT MEAN TO DO THAT AND IS
THERE ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE
TO GO TO SAY THE PLEASE THANK
YOU SAID ABOUT VERY WELL OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL WE DO HAVE ONE
LEAD WITNESS- IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR LIVE LINE NOW
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME NICOLE
CORINNE IN. SHE IS WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE THE
SCREEN YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THE BILL THE FLOOR
IS. YOURS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
AND WELCOME TO COMMITTEE. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. ON
THE COOKER REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
COOKING TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FORTINO TO. LAST YEAR
E-COMMERCE ACCOUNTED FOR MORE
THAN 20% OF ALL RETAIL SALES
JUMPING BY THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE EVER RECORDED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. WITH INCREASED
USE OF E. COMMERCE. ONLINE
RETAIL PLATFORMS KNOWN AS
MARKETPLACE ELEVATORS CURRENTLY
MARKETPLACE DISTILLATE HERE'S
ARE CONSIDERED RETAILERS ONLY
FOR SALES TAX PURPOSES THEY DO
NOT COLLECT AND REMIT FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE IMPACT THAT
SOME PRODUCTS HAVE ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AS REQUIRED BY
RETAILERS IN CALIFORNIA. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE SPONSOR
CALIFORNIA LANDMARK E. WASTE
LAW WHICH CREATED A FEE TO FIND
E. WASTE RECYCLING. THIS
LEGISLATION WAS PART OF THE
STATE APERTURES RECYCLE
HAZARDOUS PRODUCTS THAT WERE
ENDING UP IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
INCLUDING THE E. WASTE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS TIRES LIKELY
AND LEAD ACID BATTERY RECYCLING.
THE RETAIL SHIFT TO MARKET
PLACE IS STILL TEETERS
CURRENTLY REPRESENTS A HUGE LOT
OF FUNDS FOR PROGRAMS DUE TO
LACK OF COMPLAINT IN THE
COLLECTION. PRODUCTS IMPACTING
THE ENVIRONMENT CAN STILL BE
SOLD IN THE STATE WITHOUT THE
FEES MAKING THEIR WAY OF THESE
CRITICAL MEDICATION RECYCLING
PROGRAMS. WHEN RETAILERS SELL
ITEMS ON THE SITE THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTING THE
SB AN ASSESSMENT AND THE
MARKETPLACE TO SOLICITORS
COLLECTS HILLS AND USE TAX
CREATING A- CONFUSING AND
BURDENSOME PROCESS FOR
RETAILERS. UNDER AB FORTINO TO
MARKET PLACE SO IT HEATERS WILL
BE REQUIRED TO REGISTER COLLECT
AND REMIT ALL FEES UNDER THE
FEE COLLECTIONS PROCEDURES LAW.
STREAMLINING PROCESSES AND
INCREASING COMPLAINTS FOR FEE
COLLECTION FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ESTIMATED THIS WILL
RESULT IN A ONE MILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL INCREASE IN FPL REVENUES
APPROPRIATELY REFLECTING THESE
PRODUCTS SOLD IN THE STATE. AND
MAINTAINING THE INTENTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S. ENVIRONMENTAL
PROGRAM. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF A GREAT FROM THE
COLD A LAZY WE ONE SUPPORT
WITNESS ON THE LINE- AND NOW
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO THOSE
WHO MAY WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS HERE AND SEE KNOWN
RISE WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM HEARING SEEN
KNOWN IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LIVE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN OH TWO. NOW MR
MODERATOR. I GET AFTERNOON
SUPPORT AB FORTINO TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
I AM VERY GRATEFUL MR MODERATOR
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE TURNING
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
AB FORTINO TOO WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION ON RECORD HERE
TODAY. SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO THREE KAREN SCENE NO ONE
RISE FOR NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM KNOWN AS INNER
OVERFLOW ROOM WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE. MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS OPPOSED TO AB FORTINO
TOO. NOW IF ANYONE IS OPPOSED
AB FORTINO TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN JUST
A MOMENT WHILE THE- GRAB THE
FIRST COMMONER. OKAY IN.
BECAUSE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T OFTEN ON BEHALF
OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION WE'VE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION MIGHT
OCCUR SOMEBODY JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND STAFF
FOR. WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALRIGHT LADIES IN GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE RECEIVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS OR
EMOTION. MISTER MISTER. WHICH I
CAN MAKE A MOTION ON YEAH AB
FORTY TWO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
AB FOURTEEN OH TWO ASSEMBLY
RELIVING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU AS WELL TO
MISTER GUNNELL FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND TO THE-
ALL STAKEHOLDERS RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION ARE STRUCK LAST FOR
A VOTE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS. REALLY GOOD TO SEE SIR.
MISTER NOW WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR AND AB FORTINO TO BY
THE VICE CHAIR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE MOTION AND THEN
CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE WIRE AYE AYES SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN A SENATOR
DORADO. SENATOR HERTZBERG
SENATOR WINER CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A TWO ZERO VOTERS YOUR VOTE
WILL KEEP DEVELOPING THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND REMOVING FOR VERY
GRATEFUL GOOD TO SEE IF. RIGHT
LAYS IN GERMAN ARMY MOVING ON
HER LAST BILL THE DAY THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B. SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT INNOCENT SYRIAN AS
SOME MEMBERS COULD YOU SEE SIR.
AS A MEMBER YOU DO HAVE A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL- WE WOULD RESPECTIVELY
REQUEST A TRUNCATED VERSION OF
YOUR STATEMENT AS YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEE. THE NUMBER IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
ESPECIALLY FOR YOU MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES- YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
IN AB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I
FIRST WANT TO SAY THANKS TO YOU
AND YOUR WONDERFUL STAFF FOR
WORKING AND COLLABORATING WITH
MY TEAM- VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR- THE CONVERSATIONS AND-
YOUR- HELP IN MOVING THIS
FORWARD- THIS IS. AN ISSUE
AREAS THAT I'VE WORKED ON SINCE
MY FIRST TERM IN OFFICE
STARTING ABOUT NINE YEARS AGO
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO HELP. GIVE
PUBLIC UTILITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO- HAVE
REDUCED BONDS SO THAT CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS CAN HAPPEN AT A
LOWER COST TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
NOW I'M- OF MOVING IT FORWARD
ON THE INVESTOR OWNED AND SO I
WILL THAT'LL BE MY TRUNCATED
VERSION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND- WITH ME ARE.
A PATRICK WELCH SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF ENERGY AT THE CMU EIGHT AS
WELL AS PAUL HAUSER GENERAL
MANAGER OF. TRINITY PUBLIC
UTILITIES DISTRICT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
SEVERAS ARIAN APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS WERE STILL WAITING
FOR MR WATCH BILL TO JOIN US
BUT THAT'S GO IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU AS A MEMBER. LET'S GO
TO THE ONE THE ONLY PAUL HAUSER
HE'S THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
TRINITY PUBLIC UTILITIES
DISTRICT. WE WELCOME- MISTER
HOUSE ARE ALWAYS A COMMITTEE
THANK HIM FOR HIS. INCREDIBLE
WORK ON BEHALF OF T. TIED IN OF
COURSE THE PEOPLE TRINITY
COUNTY. MR HOUSER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT. PLEASE
PROCEED- GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
VIRUN COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AGAIN-
I'M POLICIES ON THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR TWENTY PUBLIC
UTILITIES DISTRICT. ON BEHALF
ATTORNEY PD I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. THE PD
PROVIDES A 100% CARBON FREE
ELECTRICITY TO APPROXIMATELY
TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVE IN
A WORLD TRYING TO COUNTING. OUR
SERVICE TERRITORY COVERS TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED SQUARE MILES OF
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST FIRE
PRONE LAND. THE POPULATION WE
SERVE IS ALSO AMONG THE POOREST
IN CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT OF
CALIFORNIA'S STRICT LIABILITY
STANDARD AT LEAST AS IT RELATES
TO UTILITY WILDFIRE LIABILITY
TWENTY P. U. D. IS NO LONGER
ABLE TO PROCURE WHILE OUR
LIABILITY INSURANCE. NOT ONLY
DOES THIS EXPOSE THE UTILITY
CONSIDERABLE BANKRUPTCY RISK
BUT IT ALSO HAS RESULTED IN A
SIGNIFICANT DOWNGRADE YOUR
CREDIT RATING. WE LAST
REFINANCE DEBT ON NOVEMBER
FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHEN OUR
CREDIT RATING WAS A DOUBLING
MINUS THE DAY ARE CREDIT RATING
IS A TRIPLE BE PLUS. THIS IS
INCREASED OUR COST OF ACQUIRING
CAPITAL JUST WHEN WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS TO EXPAND OUR
RIGHTS OF WAY AND FIRE HARD IN
OUR SYSTEM. AB SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT HOLD THE POTENTIAL TO
REDUCE OUR BORROWING COST WHAT
THEY WERE PRIOR TO OUR RIGHT
PRIOR TO OUR CREDIT RATING
DOWNGRADE SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. THAT WILL REDUCE
FIRE. RISK AND MAKE ELECTRIC
SERVICE MORE RELIABLE. BUT
TRINITY COUNTY BEING THE
POOREST THINK. DIFFICULT MAKE
LARGE CAPITAL EXPENDITURES
WITHOUT FINANCING THE EXPENSES
IN SPREADING THE COST OVER
TIME. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT SO THE TWENTY P. U.
D. AND OTHER PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES CAN ACCESS LOWER COST
FINANCING. THANK YOU ARE REALLY
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY- WE DO NOW HAVE. PATRICK
WELCH FROM THE CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION MISTER
WELCH WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED STATEMENT AS- SOME
MEMBERS IN THE SYRIAN HAS.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL
TODAY MISTER WELCH WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CARTER CARE
ALL BE BRIEF JUST APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. WORK IN THE
AUTHOR ON THIS ISSUE. AND JUST
SAY THAT- AFFORDABLE
ELECTRICITY IS REALLY
ESSENTIAL- IN CALIFORNIA AND
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT I CAN
IMPORTANT TOOL. TO THE STATE
FORTY SIX PUBLIC ON BANKS
UTILITIES. TO MAKE IS NEEDED
AND REQUIRED INVESTMENTS AT
CHEAPER COSTS TO CUSTOMERS. AND
CREATE YOUR SUPPORT AND- DRIVE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH RESTAURANTS VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR YOUR WORK AS WELL LAYS IN
GERMAN COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA.
NOW TURN TO THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT. IN ADDITION TO OUR
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES WERE
GONNA LOOK TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE WE HAVE NO ONE HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. WANTING
TO SPEAK WITH NO ONE IN OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM. THAT WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LIVE LINE
CHECKING WITH OUR MODERATOR.
MISTER MODERATOR AT THIS IS
GOING TO BE OUR FINAL BILL FOR
THE DAY. LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE A
B. ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE THE MAP NOW. IT
DOES IN SUPPORT OF. AB SEVEN
FIVE EIGHT PLEASE. PRESS ONE
AND ZERO THIS TIME WILL START
AT LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANASTASIA
CULTURE COULD CALIFORNIANS
VISORS ON BEHALF OF SMOG IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY P. THANK
YOU THANKS ANASTASIA. PRECEDED
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SPECIAL GOT A LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ACROSS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BURBANK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH KERN
PROCEEDED NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS TO A LINE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING HEATHER
DOLLAR WITH THE CITY OF PALO
ALTO UTILITIES DEPARTMENT ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR THE PHONE CALL TODAY
NEXT CALLER. ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMORIES TATUM
AFTER A CAMPAIGN ADVISERS ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POWER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IT WILL GO TO
ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREG
COOKS BUT BEHALF OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER EIGHT
AGENCY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WAS COULD
HEAR VOICE MISTER COOK THAT'S
GO TO OUR NEXT LINE. AND JUST
WHEN WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT'S
QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHTS SECOND.
WE WANT WE WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
IF YOU LIKE TO BE A CALLING ON
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE EIGHT THE
PHONE NUMBER IS. 877-336-4436
LET'S CHECK IN WITH OUR
MODERATOR SOUNDS LIKE WE MAY
HAVE ONE LAST CALLER IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR. OKAY THEIR NECKS
WE'LL GO TO LINE. THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS THEIR DOLPHIN APPELLEES
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER.
LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR. AND YES WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE THAT'S QUEUED UP. AND
JUST SMALL- GIVEN THE LINE
NUMBER ALL RIGHT. WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S PATIENCE WE'RE
GONNA BE QUEUING UP OUR FINAL
COLOR IN SUPPORT. OKAY WE HAVE
LINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ANTHONY CANO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU MR TANAM
PRECIADO. NEXT TIME PLEASE MR
MODERATOR. MR IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU MISTER
MODERATOR LET'S NOW TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO AB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT
WITH NO LEAD WITNESSES ON
RECORD TODAY WE ARE GOING TO
CHECKING TO SEE IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
CURRENCY KNOWN RISE FOR NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM HERE IN CHINO AND RISE IN
THE VERFLOW ROOM. BURNETT
CHECK BACK IN ONE LAST TIME
WITH OUR MODERATOR MR MODERATOR
GREAT WORKING WITH YOU TODAY
SIR LET'S SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP NOW. AND
IF ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LOOKING CURRENTLY FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT THE MODERATORS KILLING
FOLKS UP MISTER MODERATOR HOW
WE LOOKING- WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BE
BRINGING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE I
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE'D LIKE TO BE TO
SEE IF THERE IS A MOTION.
THAT'S THE QUESTION SO WE HAVE
A WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR MOTION BY VICE YOU'RE
NIELSEN WHERE TO GO TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG. ZERO
THANK YOU JOINT OPPORTUNISTS
ASK A SERIES OF QUESTIONS I
WANT TO ASK OF. ASSEMBLY MAN
HERE. HE'S ACTUALLY REPRESENTS
ME AND SO I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN IT THAT PEN READY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE AGO.
ALREADY GREAT DEAL OF WORK I
WANT TO FIRST START OUT. IS
WITH RESPECT TO. THIS MEASURE
THAT THINKING TO AMANDA'S. THE
MARKS RUSA MEASURE. AS YOU MAY
KNOW FROM THE DAYS I'M SURE IS
A STUDENT OF PUBLIC POLICY AND
YOU ARE YOU NEW HOWARD MARKS.
NO MILTON MARK STONE GOOD
MELTING MILTIE MARKS ON
CAMILLUS AGAIN HOWARD MARKS
THAT'S- NEW YORK. MILTIE MARKS
UNCLE MILTIE MARKS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. REPUBLICAN WHO WAS
A- WONDERFUL GENTLEMAN REALLY
ACTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
CERTAINLY MISTER BRUCE. WHO
SERVED HERE IS- SPEAKER PRO TEM
AND MAJORITY LEADER IN THE
OTHER HOUSE AND SERVED DISTRICT
EDUCATION TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT YOU REPRESENT ACTUALLY
OVERLAPS LIBERTY OR DISTRICT.
AND I GOT TO REPRESENT HIM
BRIEFLY UNTIL HE MOVED OUT OF
MY DISTRICT TO LOOK LIKE WHEN
HE WAS THERE ARE YOU HAVING TO
LOOK THAT'S RIGHT. IN THE HOUSE.
OF PALM SPRINGS. SO THE
QUESTION IS FIRST QUESTIONS YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THE UNDERLYING
PURPOSE OF THIS MEASURE I
CERTAINLY. UNFORTUNATELY NOT
MARKSON REMARKS PASSED AWAY-
GREAT GREAT PERSON WHEN I
BECAME CHAIR OF THE YOUTH
COMMISSION THE SEVENTIES HE WAS
THE ONLY ONE TO WRITE ME A
LETTER OF CONGRATULATIONS AND
I'LL NEVER FORGET THAT. SO BIG
DEAL IN THOSE DAYS. BUT GIVE ME
A CHANCE TARTUS ASSEMBLY REUSS
ABOUT THIS BILL TO GET SOME
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HIS INTENT
WAS I NEVER DID FOLLOW UP WITH
HIM. I ALWAYS BELIEVE THAT THE
INTENTION WAS TO PROVIDE TOOLS
SO THAT THE LOCAL MUNICIPAL
AGENCIES CAN BETTER BE ABLE TO
SERVE. AND PROVIDE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT. DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA IF BASED UPON OFFERING
THIS AUTHORITY TO RATE
REDUCTION BOND SOUNDS GOOD. MY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND FRIEND BUT
DO WE KNOW ANY DATA SET AS TO
WHAT WE THINK THE RATES ARE OR
IS FOR THE ELECTRICAL UTILITIES
PROBABLY DEPARTMENT OF WATER
AND POWER THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. GERMANY ESTIMATES- IT
WHAT YOU THINK IT MIGHT SAVE
THEM IF WE WERE TO GOING TO THE
MARKETS NOW. APPLYING YOUR LAW
ANY IDEA ON THE OBVIOUSLY IT'S
AN ISSUE OF- SCALE OF ECONOMY.
SO THE BIGGER THE PROJECT- MORE
SAVINGS IT IS BUT FROM
EVERYTHING I UNDERSTAND. AND
THERE ARE PART OF THE REASON
WHY I STARTED WORKING ON THIS
ABOUT. MY FIRST TERM OF OFFICE.
WAS TO HELP WITH THE
UNDERGROUND WATER CLEAN UP.
SINCE WE NEVER REALLY GOT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO FROM BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES RIGHT SO ONE OF THE
WAYS OF DOING IT WAS FOR LA
CITY TO FIGURE OUT THROUGH ITS
MUNICIPAL. THROUGH THE W. P.
HOW CAN WE- BETTER FIGHT HOW
CAN WE EVEN REALIZE WHATEVER-
TOOLS WE HAVE IN OUR ARSENAL.
TO GET THE BEST RATE. TO
FINANCE LONG TERM CLEANUP
EFFORTS AND THESE CLEAN UP
EFFORTS GIVEN THE BROMIDE GIVEN
EVERYTHING THAT'S CONTAMINATING
OUR EXISTING UNDERGROUND WATER.
CAN TAKE UP. POTENTIALLY UP TO
SEVENTY YEARS- SO WE WERE- THE
ALLEY AQUIFER BY THE WAY IS THE
SECOND LARGEST NATURALLY
EXISTING AQUIFER THAT WE HAVE
IN THE COUNTRY SO IT'S QUITE A
BIT OF A DEPTH AND IT'S GOING
TO TAKE QUITE A BIT OF. WORK TO
CLEAN UP SO WITH THERE WERE
THREE SITES THAT WE WERE GOING
TO BE THAT DWP WAS LOOKING AT
DEVELOPING. AND SO BASED ON
THAT WE WERE WE STARTED WORKING
ON THIS BILL WITH THE W. P. TO
ENSURE THAT THEY GET THE BEST
RATE POSSIBLE AND FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THIS WOULD
WORK IS. IF WE ESTABLISH A G.
P. THAT HAS NO LIABILITIES THEN
WE'RE GONNA BE GETTING THE BEST
RATE REDUCED RATE HENCE RATE
REDUCTION- TO BE ABLE TO
FINANCE THESE MAJOR CAPITAL
PROJECTS AND TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION SPECIFICALLY. FOR LED
W. PEACE THREE PROJECTS WE'RE
LOOKING AT A SAVINGS OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS. SIGNIFICANT
FOREIGN MONEY PAIRS IS IT A
HORRIBLE STATEMENT I REALLY
GIVE A LOT OF REGARD FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS AND I'VE
WATCHED OVER THE YEARS IS
REALLY HORRIBLE STATEMENT THAT
HERE WE HAD THIS INCREDIBLE
AQUIFER THAT FORM THE
FOUNDATION OF THE WATER SYSTEM
UNDER- MISTER MULHOLLAND WAY
BACK WHEN WE'VE POLLUTED SO
BADLY THAT IT IMPEDES OUR
ABILITY TO- TO BASICALLY USE
THAT GROUNDWATER AND REDUCE THE
DEMAND ON AGRICULTURAL AREAS OF
THE STATE THE NORTHERN PART OF
THE STATE. THE COLORADO RIVER
IN A LIKE IT REALLY IS HORRIBLE
SO WHAT I WANT TO TELL YOU SIR.
IS DESPITE ME TRYING TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF OUR TIME TO
RUN MY FRIEND THROUGH THE
GAUNTLET. I APPLAUD YOU WITH
GREAT VIGOR FOR DOING THIS. I
THINK IT'S A BRILLIANT IDEA AT
EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT SAVES
MONEY IT'S TELOGEN AT EVERY
LEVEL. AND I WOULD BE HONORED
TO IN ADDITION TO MOVE IT. I'D
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE IF YOU WOULD SO
ACCOMMODATE ME BECAUSE I'D LIKE
TO JOIN YOU IN THIS MARCH. IT
WOULD GREATLY HONOR ME AND I
KNEW I NEEDED NEEDED TO BE VERY
PREPARED. TO ANSWER ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE BEING OF
BECOMING. ESPECIALLY FROM MY
ESTEEMED FORMER SPEAKER. FROM
WHERE I GET TO REPRESENT NOW.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WAS CHAIRMAN
AMBERGATE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISS MAJORITY LEADER AND THINK
YOU SEND THE NUMBER. ALL RIGHT
SO LAYS IN GERMAN WE HAVE- WE
HAVE A MOTION- BY THE WAY SAID
MUCH BETTER VICE CHAIR BUT
WE'RE GOING TO SAY WE TO
MOTIONS IT IS SUCH A POPULAR
BILL SIR. ON THE FLOOR BUT AT
THE SENATE HEARING WHAT YOU-
CLUBS THINKING. THANK YOU I
THINK THAT CONVERSATION WAS
ALREADY CLOSED. THANK YOU AGAIN
VERY MUCH TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
MISTER TO CARE FOR YOUR WORK
WITH OUR OFFICE. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SEASON NUMBER
THINK LIKE AND I THINK YOU'RE A
GRATEFUL TO WORK WITH YOU. ALL
RIGHT SO THIS YEAR WE HAVE A
MOTION BY VICE CHAIR NIELSEN ON
THE FLOOR AND AB SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT. THAT MR NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL IN CALL
THE MOTION. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE
FIVE SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN.
A SENATOR DRAWS SO. SENATOR
HURTS. PURGED HI SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI. IT'S A FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN TO HAVE SENATOR OUTSIDE ON
A SUMMER'S HEARING IF THAT
WORKS FOR YOU. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
DON'T KNOW IF I ANSWERED MY
SENATORS QUESTION BUT A. B. I
THINK I SAID I'D BE. HONORED TO
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALRIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN VICE CHAIR NIELSEN
HE'S ON IT HE'S ON EVERY BILL
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
VICE CHAIR AS ALWAYS- FOR YOUR
WORK ONE REMIND FOLKS THAT-
ITEM NUMBER. FOUR MISTER
MULLIN- THAT BILL WAS
TEMPORARILY PULLED WILL SEE
THAT YOU'RE PROBABLY NEXT WEEK
SO- WE ARE ALSO WAITING FOR
MISS DRAWS A MISTER HAS THOSE
AT LIVING THE DREAM INSURANCE
AND CURRENTLY PRESENTING. SO
THAT WILL BE WILL BE HEARING
FROM HER IN JUST A MOMENT BUT
LET'S GET EVERYONE ELSE ON THE
BILLS LET'S START WITH OUR-
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER
ONE IN IEM NUMBER FIVE ARE ON
THE KITCHEN COUNTER ITEM NUMBER
ONE IN ITEM NUMBER FIVE ARE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MISTER
GRINNELL WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
FOUR EIGHT ZERO VOTE ON THE
CONTENT COUNTER CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI AT THE
FIVE ZERO VOTE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BLAZING CHEN ON
COMMITTEE WERE NOW TO ME
STARTING WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO
THAT'S AB FIVE FOUR FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ONE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. MR GRINNELL. THE
MEASURE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
FIVE SENATOR WIENER. WIENER I
FOR ONE VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE WE'RE
NOT GONNA. BE MOVING ON TO. I
ITEM NUMBER. I REMEMBER SIX
THAT'S ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LEVINE
ITEM NUMBER SIX DECEMBER THE
DENABY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
FOURTEEN OF TWO CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO ZERO MISTER NOW SENATOR
DORADO. SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HIS SENATOR WIENER
WIENER FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AND
WE'RE KEEPING THE ROLE OPEN ON
ITEM NUMBER THREE IN ITEM
NUMBER SIX FOR SENATOR RAZA WHO
IS CURRENTLY IN INSURANCE.
OTHERWISE SINCE MAJORITY LEADER
MR VICE CHAIR MISTER SENATOR-
YOU'RE FREE TO LEAVE HOPE YOU
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND. THAT
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA TAKE
A TEMPORARY RECESS AS WE WAIT
FOR IT SENATOR DORADO TO HEAD
ON BACK AFTER FOR A
PRESENTATION INSURANCE.
SENATOR
RAZA CENTER DRAWS AS BEEN
LIVING THE DREAM TODAY RUNNING
FROM ONE COMMITTEE THE OTHERS
YOU. HAVE TO GO INSURANCE OR GO
ALL RIGHT. BEEN GREAT ALL RIGHT
WING GREAT GOT GOOD REPORTS-
COMING FROM INSURANCE COMMITTEE
THAT'S GOOD NEWS. SO THAT TO
ADD TO ANSWER DRAWS ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT MISTER NAZARIAN.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE MR NOW PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ALSO. DURAZO HI
ALL RIGHT THAT'S A FIVE ZERO
VOTE FIVE ZERO BIPARTISAN LOVE
RIGHT THERE WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE ROLE IN THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THEIR DRAWS-
ITEM NUMBER SIX FINAL BILL THE
DAVEY FORTINO TOO ISN'T OVER
THE THEME. CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
FOUR ZERO VOTE MISTER PER NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR TORONTO. TORONTO HI
FIVE ZERO VOTES FOR THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
LAYS IN GERMAN PLEASE PLAN FOR
TWO TO THREE HOUR MEETING NEXT
WEEK- WE HAVE SOME B. V. BILLS
ARE GONNA BE COMING UP NEXT
WEEK IN THE WEEK AFTER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO OUR SERGEANTS MR
CANAL INTO THE ENTIRE GUNFIGHT
TEAM AS ALWAYS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.